Good morning, Hank, it's Wednesday.
Great top ten list on Monday;
today, it's time for my top ten list:
Top Ten Animal Power Moves!
...God, I love power moves.
Power move number ten belongs to the Bombardier beetle.
Hank, when the Bombardier beetle is threatened,
it turns around and sprays boiling hot acid
out of its butt!
Power move number nine: giraffes.
You know how I love giraffes, Hank.
Giraffes are like the Chuck Norris of the
animal kingdom.
When they roundhouse kick you,
you forget what time it is.
A giraffe kick has been known to
decapitate a lion!
Power move number eight, and one of my personal favorites,
comes from Cantor's giant softshell turtle.
Now, Hank, we know
the power move for regular turtles:
it's their hard green shells,
and we know the power move for red turtles:
it's their heat-seeking red shells.
But the power move for a softshell turtle
is motionlessness.
Yes, Hank, Cantor's softshell turtle covers
himself with sand
in a riverbank
and then sits completely still
for twenty-three and a half hours a day,
moving only when something crosses his path
that he can eat.
That actually sounds a lot like my life,
only Cantor's softshell turtle gets to live
on the beach
and I have to live in Indianapolis.
Power move number seven belongs to Trichobatrachus Robostus,
which is a frog, and when he's threatened
he breaks a bone in his own foot
and then uses the bone fragment
from his compound fracture
as a claw to stab you!
Power move number six is the cuttlefish.
So, Hank, cuttlefish can turn into crazy colours.
They can light up blue and green
and orange and yellow,
and they'll swim over to some prey,
and they'll start lighting up, as if to say,
"Here's the party! Check it out!
I'm a disco ball! Come and party with me!
This is a crazy rave!
OH WAIT!
You just got eaten."
Power move number five: baby potato beetles.
Hank, grown-up potato beetles have hard shells,
which makes it harder for predators to eat them,
but baby potato beetles don't.
Fortunately, they have poisonous poop.
It's so rare in life that the word 'fortunately'
precedes the words 'they have poisonous poop.'
So what the baby potato beetles do is
they poop and then they cover
their whole bodies
in that poisonous poop to discourage predators.
Power move!
Power move number four: Mabra elephantophila.
Hank, we all know that
elephants have awesome power moves
like stomping and painting pictures,
but I would argue that the moth Mabra elephantophila
has an even better power move,
which is feasting on the tears of elephants.
Yes, Hank, there is a moth that gets most
of its sustenance from eating elephant tears,
and when the elephants aren't crying
enough on their own,
the moth will go in and scratch at their eyes to make them cry more.
Power move number three:
the Australian funnel-web spider.
Hank, everybody in America is so afraid of
Black Widow spiders,
but funnel-web spiders in Australia are like
for real with their power moves.
For instance, they're very aggressive, and
their fangs can shoot through human fingernails.
[Cell phone rings]
...That's so scary, someone had to
call me about it.
Power move number two: the duck billed platypus.
Hank, not only are platypi one of the very
few mammals that lay eggs,
they also have a sixth sense - no joke -
called 'electrolocation.'
Platypi can use their fat little bills to
sense electromagnetic fields,
which means that the moment one of their predators moves a muscle -
literally contracts a muscle -
the platypi knows which direction
that muscle is headed.
It's like a literal superpower,
only it's contained
inside of a glorified beaver.
And Hank, my number-one power move in the
animal kingdom goes to
camponotus saundersi, a carpenter ant.
So, Hank, when this ant is in a fight and
he notices that he's going to lose,
instead of like fighting to the death or whatever,
he gets as close to his prey as possible,
and then blows himself up.
These ants have these poisonous glands that
run the entire length of their body,
and when they realize
they're about to lose a fight,
they contract their abdominal muscles so intensely
that their entire body explodes,
sending the poison flying.
Nerdfighters, I can't wait to read
your favorite animal power moves in the comments.
It's been fascinating to read about all of the diseases that you have.
Hank, I will see you and
your last top ten list on Friday;
don't forget to be awesome.